uh spongebob is talking a lot about
global warming and he's only looking at
it from
one point of view why i hate the news
brainwashed by the mainstream media
santa just
is white jesus was a white man too he
wrote a sentence ending with a brand new
word the president and a small group of
people know exactly what he meant
seems like a weird title for me to use
because i'm a journalist
at least that's what i think i am i
worked at a journalistic institution
i just did a piece at the new york times
can i can you call me a journalist i'm a
journalist right
now i'm feeling insecure okay so
whatever i'm a journalist but i kind of
hate the news
let me explain cnn breaking news
tonight it all comes down to this so
let's just first
define what the news is or
should be the news or the press or the
fourth estate the sort of
sacred thing is meant to be a
magnifying glass on our society it's
meant to look at the things that are
really important
to make people stand accountable to
highlight the issues that you should be
thinking about when you're voting or
going about your day-to-day life it's
meant to give you important information
about
things like i don't know pandemics
clearly nickelodeon is pushing a global
warming
agenda in short it's meant to keep the
people
informed and aware of what is important
in the world but as a news consumer
myself and as someone who wants
to be informed and to understand how the
world works i
find that the news less and less and
less actually helps me do that
it is not right now
in these dishonesties so i've been
thinking about this and i want to share
it with you
i'm going to give you three reasons why
i hate
the news number one the news often tells
you
what isn't actually happening in the
world there's this onion article that
just sums it up so well
point zero zero zero three percent of
things that happen
actually matter often times we look at
the news and we see
crazy things that are happening around
the world if there is a
mass homicide that will be national news
tomorrow morning if there's a terrorist
attack
around the world that will be national
news tomorrow morning if a prominent
politician
says something really embarrassing that
will be national news tomorrow morning
what's the naughtiest thing you ever did
i have to confess when
me and my friends sort of used to run
through the fields of wheat
um the farmers weren't too pleased about
that what all these things have in
common is that they don't happen very
often they're super rare
they don't teach us anything about how
the world actually
works they teach us about how the world
doesn't work and how sometimes it does
the outliers the aberrations my big
problem with this is that someone who
reads the news every day
and uses it as their gateway into the
world will often walk away
with a completely delusional version of
how the world works
they will assume that terrible things
happen more often than they actually do
our view of the world is at stake here
when the information available to us is
the stuff that doesn't happen very often
the stuff that's actually an aberration
from the norm we get a distorted view of
how the world works
number two the news has become way too
fun meeting with a pirate no problem
tonight president donald trump fighting
for a second term
as a deadly pandemic gets worse
my old colleague carlos mazza has
thought a lot about how fun the news has
become i called him up and we
chatted about it how are you i don't
think to see your face you see for long
as long as we've had corporate news in
america is that we have a product that
is trying to meet
two very different objectives or a
suitable
incentive what carlos explained to me
that was really helpful was that
the news has two opposing incentives the
first incentive is what i talked about
at the beginning of this video which is
to inform the people to
teach you what you should care about to
give you a framework for
understanding the world for highlighting
important information that the public
should know
but then there's this other incentive
corporate media is trying to sell you a
product and they sell your product by
making you think you need
as much of it as humanly possible all
the time
so newscast should be maybe an hour
every day and then you're done like go
do your thing you have this other
incentive though that's why you have a
corporate media environment that is like
always breaking
[Music]
there's always a new thing that you have
to worry about so you have this
basically impossible impasse of a
product that you should not really need
that much ensures a specific function
being run by companies that want you to
need it all the time president i am not
distracting
what i've been doing for over a year and
a half i haven't been doing that the
hell yeah
what this does is it incentivize
programming
that is optimized to appeal to our
senses
whether it's fear-based sensationalism
or whether it's flashy graphics
article titles that are a little bit
click-baity the economic incentive that
is built into news
makes it really difficult for news to
honor that first incentive
i called him a [ __ ] and then i modified
that word with a vulgar
vulgar anglo-saxon term that is also
intelligible in dutch and instead
to prioritize entertainment and false
feelings of
this is important or this is scary
this is cnn breaking news it seems like
a really dangerous thing to be
so subject to economic forces okay my
number three
is that the news tricks you into feeling
informed for a long time i read the news
every single day i would go on and read
multiple different outlets and i would
feel that day like
check okay i believe that i'm an
informed smart person and i've just sort
of confirmed that belief
because there's this sort of like
glorification of the person who's like
really up on the daily news
what i've learned is that that's
actually not the case a lot of people
just
check out and that's a legitimate
response like if the town crier in your
village was constantly screaming 10 000
horrific things at you
from other villages that you don't live
in after all you'd stop really
meaningfully listening to it because
your brain cannot sort out
what catastrophe is real and meaningful
and what you shouldn't respond to so you
have this like kind of ambient anxiety
always that
um makes it so that your brain becomes
numb to the drug you stop really caring
about what you
engage in spending a lot of time chasing
the news cycle
is a lot of mental energy it's a lot of
mental energy that could be applied
to understanding how the world actually
works
consuming things that actually shed
light on important issues like
policy or i don't know historical trends
that maybe are not as flashy and
reactive but are
way more indicative on how the world
works
how things get done how change gets made
in a society
instead because of this entertainment
incentive the news doesn't
actually end up being super informative
you're not actually
learning a lot about anything other than
what happened that day
who said what to whom and why and then
how a billion people reacted to why that
person said whom and it's like it
becomes a giant
gossip fest almost binge watch like the
rockford files
netflix are modern love more that's
terrible no it was really modern love
makes me
sick how about person of interest oh i
like that that's a good show can i say
something now no
it's almost built to appeal more to our
gossip impulse than
to our desire to learn about the world
the epitome of this is the sort of like
pseudo debate format that a lot of
tv news takes part in the five
five-person
talking head panel you have moderator
who us pretends to be relatively neutral
and then four commentators two from the
left two from the right who are arguing
about whatever the topic of the date
that
format is a straight rip from espn
like those formats are a carbon copy of
the arguing and almost like a reality tv
model that has been used in sports media
for a while
this is not journalism this looks like
journalism because it looks like there's
a robust debate going on you're abusing
power right now
stop filibustering her but journalism is
about evidence
it's about going out and gathering
evidence and scrutinizing it and then
putting it together
and presenting it to a reader in this
sensationalized news segment
no evidence is being examined or
scrutinized or cross-examined
it serves no educational function
regardless of what you think about
politics watching two people argue is
not
informative because it's too fast-paced
it triggers your tribal defenses you're
not gonna be open-minded
and there's no time to examine evidence
no matter how long that fight goes on
for you are not gonna learn anything
meaningful
from it all will happen is that you will
leave thinking god i really hate the
other side and god by side is so right
it's the opposite of what journalism
should be doing
you don't leave a debate like this any
more informed all you do
is leave a debate like this with like an
understanding that your side is right
the other side is wrong and like how
awesome
that like the people who represented
your side were like so hard
on the opposing side which is a super
awesome impulse if you're like
in a football stadium watching your
favorite team play but when we're
talking about like real issues and real
policy
this sports framework of commentary and
fighting
is not very useful because it tricks
people into thinking that they're
informed that they're like oh i get the
issues now because i watched that debate
but instead
all they were was entertained i'm tired
of having this discussion
over and over again so those are my
three reasons
for why i hate the news but let me just
say one thing which is there is still
amazing journalism being done right now
really
important journalism that is
communicating important evidence
about important ideas that truly can
inform you about how the world works
the incentives of this industry make it
harder and harder for that journalism
to happen but the journalists who are
out there collecting evidence reporting
on
really difficult things talking to lots
of experts trying to piece together
all of this information so that they can
inform the public those are the people
who are doing this work
in spite of the entertainment corporate
24-hour news cycle that has sort of
taken over
what news should be and what i really
believe and
i learned this working at vox a place
that really focused on
context and explainer journalism there's
a demand for it there will always be a
demand
a voyeuristic demand for seeing terrible
things happen there will always be
demand for
entertainment and shouting matches but i
believe that most people want to
understand they want to understand
why this certain policy will work and
the other one won't they want to
understand the real
debates the philosophical and political
debates that are happening
in our system they want to understand
how our system
works or doesn't work and if only our
news industry
could focus more on that desire that
desire to understand
instead of this facade of information
that is really just
entertainment the media is shoving this
down your throat
by the way our ratings are great
shouldn't they for a period of time
not go on the attack they were
fear-based fear-based they were
fear-based
hate in teleprompter can you give us
don't be attacking us
you are fake news all right well that
was a
little bit of a rant just taking some
deep breaths glad i got that out of my
system
if you want a place to put your rants
and thoughts
out into the world choose squarespace
which is a one-stop shop where you can
build an online presence as someone who
runs an internet business and thinks
about internet
community and marketing and all this
stuff squarespace truly does
have an amazing set of tools for
developing a voice and a presence on the
internet and doing so in a beautiful way
they've got these templates that are
like really
nice looking and well designed it's all
easy and drag and drop it's not like
code
you go back and you build your website
first base supports this channel and i'm
really grateful for that there's a link
in my description if you click that link
you get 10 off your first purchase of
anything whether it's domain or hosting
service or whatever squarespace offers
10 off clicking that link helps support
this channel but
it also can kick-start your online
presence if that's something you're
thinking about doing you should check
out squarespace so thank you all for
being here
and uh for listening to my big rant
about the news
i am in the middle of brainstorming some
really fun
wild big deep videos for 2021
some international explainers that i am
working on right now that i think you're
all gonna really like and
they just take more time dude journalism
just takes more time i have to go and
like
read all this stuff talking to the
experts reading all of like the
journals and the think tank pieces and
all this stuff putting it together
that just takes time but quality
journalism is an important thing
so anyway have a great day i will talk
to you later
[Music]
global warming mr krabs